>> Okay. So, to start off
our last session we have
Eric Walkingshaw from OSU,
who's going to talk
to us about variational
programming. Please take it away.
>> I'm up here from Oregon State.
I'm one representative here.
So, I wanted to briefly
show our group.
So, this is just the
programming languages group,
we're pretty small,
just two faculty members
and some grad students,
a couple grad students
were out sick on this day,
unfortunately, but
and then we gathered
about four software engineering
faculty members as well.
So, yeah, I'm going
to be talking about
variational programming,
and this work was originally
motivated by a problem
that comes up in the context of
highly configurable
software systems.
So, the idea here is that
you have a codebase,
and this represents
not just one program,
but lots of different programs.
So, for example, it's
a software product line or
it's an open source program
that has lots of
configuration options
and features that can
be turned on or off,
and so the usual workflow for
making a running program
out of this codebase,
is the first thing that you
do is you configure it.
So, you pick the features
that you want.
I mean you generate a program
that can actually be
compiled and then maybe you do
some program analysis on that.
Make sure that it works,
run the test suite on it
and then if it works,
you can go ahead and deploy it.
So, the problem
with this workflow,
especially in the context
of open source software,
is that often the persons
that's generating
and evaluating this program
that wants to deploy it,
is not the same person that wrote
the code in the
first place, right?
So, the first person that
wrote the code they sort of
understand all of
the configurations.
The person that generates
a configuration,
it's very likely that you can
generate a configuration
that's never been
generated before because
these things have
hundreds or even thousands
of configuration options.
They don't know what to do
with the error that
they get back,
they don't even maybe
maintain this code at all.
So, this process
finds the errors too
late but the person
that writes the code,
they can't anticipate
all the configurations
that somebody might
want to generate,
there's just way
too many of them.
So, the solution to this problem
is something that we call
a variational analyses.
So, what we do is,
we instead evaluate
the configurable codebase
directly and we call this
a variational analysis,
and what this gives us,
is it gives us
a variational result.
The key thing here is that
this variational result
conceptually
represents the result for
all of the configurations
that can be
generated from this program.
So, if we apply
a configuration to
the original program and run
the standard program analysis,
we get the same
thing as if we apply
that same configuration to
the variational result.
So, now we can do things
like evaluate all
of our configurations in advance
so that the person that generates
the configuration that they
want to deploy doesn't
encounter an error.
So, we've done lots of work on
developing languages,
theory, data structures,
and algorithms to do this sort
of thing correctly and
efficiently and collectively we
call this variational
programming.
So, the first example
of this that we did,
so this is when I
was a grad student,
is variational typing, so this is
just sort of concrete instance
of this last slide here.
So, in this context,
so normally you have
lambda calculus,
you run the
Hindley-Milner algorithm,
you get a type, you infer
a type for that program.
So, here we have
a variational lambda calculus,
and we can run
variational typing on
that and get back
a variational type.
The types that are
represented here correspond
to all of the types of each
of the configurations.
Okay. In order to implement
this variational typing box here,
we need variational programming.
So, I'm going to give
an idea of what variational
programming is by an example.
This is sort of a fancy name
for a simple idea.
So, the fundamental concept
in variational programming is
something called a choice.
So, here's an expression
with a choice in it.
A choice has a dimension.
So, in this case A
and two alternatives.
So, we can select
the left or the right
branch from a dimension,
and we get the
corresponding alternative.
So, if we were to
evaluate this program
with a choice in it,
we'd get back
a variational result
with a choice in
the corresponding dimension.
If we have multiple choices
in the same dimension,
they're going to be synchronized.
So, if we evaluate this,
we'll get 12 and 23
because if we choose
the left branch from A
we get the left branch
of both choices in A.
If we have choices in
different dimensions,
they're independent.
So, if we evaluate this program,
we're going to get
four different alternatives,
corresponding to
all the four different ways
that we can configure
this expression.
The alternatives of a choice can
have different types as well.
So, here's an example of a choice
where one alternative
is a boolean and
one alternative is
an integer and so
we have choices also at
the type level here,
so here a choice
in the expression
induces a type with a choice
in the same dimension.
So, here's another example
of an expression with two
differently typed alternatives,
and what we can see here
is that when we have
a structured value,
in this case, a type, we
can push the choices
into the type.
So, this type is
exactly equivalent
to this choice type here,
which more directly corresponds
to the type of this expression.
So, successor has
type Int to Int,
even has type Int to
Bool and so we can
factor this common
Int argument out.
Okay. So, of course,
we can evaluate.
So, here's another example
of applying an example,
sorry applying two different
functions that have
two different types to
two different values.
So, the not function expects
a Boolean returns a Bool,
even expects an Int
and returns a Bool.
What we see here is
that in both cases,
the result is false, right?
So, we have two completely
different expressions
not applied to true and
even applied to three,
but both of them
returned false and
so when we return here
is just the value false.
So, we no longer have a choice.
This is equivalent
to this expression,
but we can forget
about the fact that we
had a variation there because
we don't need it going forward
and so this is going to be
key to sort of computing
efficiently with these things.
Here's just a more
complicated example.
Here this represents
four different expressions,
successor applied to two,
successor applied to four,
and even applied to
both two and four.
What we can see here is we get
a more complicated
variational value,
where one of the,
where we had some sort
of folding inside of a
or some sort of collapsing
inside of a choice.
Okay. So, that's sort of just
preserving variation
across computations.
We can also reflect
on the variation that's
in a computation.
So, here's an example
of a function vsum,
I'm not showing how
this is implemented.
But basically what this
is going to do is this
is going to look at
the alternatives that are in
the results and sum them all up.
So, it's going to sum up
all of the results here,
so this is going to
sum 12 13 22 and
23, which gives us 70.
We don't have any variation
in there anymore because we've
accumulated all of
these alternatives.
I mean we can also do
things like pick out
a particular variation here.
So here again we've got
the same expression,
and what we want to know
is, we want to know
what's the maximum
value in there.
So, we get back the value
23, but oftentimes,
we also want to know
which configuration
that value came from and
so we can return that
in the result as well.
Okay. So, that's variational
programming by example.
So, the first challenge
that comes in here is that
the space of potential variants
grows exponentially in the number
of dimensions that you have.
So, in the worst case this
is obviously very bad.
So, the trick to sort of doing
this is first of all to
share as much as possible.
So, we don't want to introduce
choices until we
absolutely have to,
so that's what I mean
by splitting late.
Anytime we have two alternatives
that converge to the same value,
we want to eliminate
choices as soon as we can.
When we have structured data,
we also need to use
clever data structures.
I'll talk about that a little
bit more here in just a second.
But probably the
most important thing
to do is just pick
the right domains.
So, some domains don't have
enough sharing in them
for this to really work.
So, if you're doing numerical
simulations or
something like that,
this probably isn't
going to work.
The other challenge is
that variation is
sort of like sand.
So, sand gets in everything,
and variation also
gets in everything.
So, when you're writing one
of these variational analyses,
the sand just gets in, the sand,
the variation just gets into
every incremental
data structure and
every incremental value
that you're working with.
So, in particular when
you have structured data,
the idea of choices just sort
of starts to break down.
So, here's a really
simple example where we
have a choice between two lists.
So, we have one, two, three
and one two, four, five.
So, we can see that there
is some redundancy here.
So, ideally we could factor
this out in some way.
So, one idea is that
we sort of push
the choices into
the list but then it's
not really clear what to
do here because we have
an element in one variant
and not in another.
So, we need
some specialized representation
for variational lists.
It turns out we sort
of need lots of
specialized variational
data structures
for different kinds
of structured data.
Originally, I had this vision
that this would all be very
systematic and the variational
data structures that worked best.
So far seem to just be
ones that we've developed
ad-hoc for each
particular domain.
So, this is something that
really still needs more work.
The other problem is what
to do about side effects.
So, when we have choices in
programs and side effects,
if you say print out
something inside of a choice,
we can't make
two copies of the word,
one where we printed out
the value and when
were we didn't.
So what do we do
there and this is
something one of my grad
students is working on.
Okay. So returning to
variational typing real quick.
This is an ideal domain
for this problem.
So, there's lots of sharing,
lots of configurations
of a program end up
having the same type,
so that's great.
It turns out that for
realistic programs,
the scales roughly linearly
with the size of the program.
So, we don't encounter
this explosion of
the variation space and
this even scales to programs
as big as the Linux kernel.
So, Christian Kastner at
CMU implemented a tool
called type chef that is
basically the same ideas
here and he can type
check all the configurations
of the Linux kernel.
It takes about a day
but it's doable.
Okay. So, variational typing
is sort of the ideal scenario.
We've done this also for
several other- us and
other people have done this
for several other analyses
of software product lines,
but it seems like this idea of
choices should be more
general than that.
So, for a while we
sort of felt like we
had this cool hammer,
and we're looking for
nails to hit with it.
Which is always sort of
an awkward position to be in.
It's not really the right
way to do research, right?
But this is what we did I guess.
So, we started thinking
about what are the properties
that make a good nail.
So, it needs to be something
that has lots of variation in it
because this is where this
variational programming idea
really pays off.
But it also needs to have lots
of sharing between
the different variants.
So, types good, numerical
simulations bad.
Okay. So, sort of
the key insight was
that the original problem or
the original program that
we're working with doesn't
necessarily need to
have the variation,
instead, we can use the idea of
variation to explore
hypothetical situations.
So, at points where
sort of in a traditional,
say program analysis,
we have to make
a decision to commit
one path or the other,
we can instead just introduce
a choice and explore both paths.
Okay, so let's look at
an example of that.
Okay, so Michael talked
about fold localization.
So, the problem of
error location in
the context of type checking
is related to this.
So, the idea here is that when
you run your type-checker,
sometimes you get a type error,
and locating where
the actual conceptual error
that caused that type
error is a hard problem.
It's been around since the 80s
and I think the research
probably looks very similar
to fold localization
where there's
sort of all these new
approaches to this,
and everyone's better
than the previous
one according to
the papers, including ours.
All right, so here's
an example of a program.
So, there's no variation
in this program,
this is just a plain
Haskell program
that exhibits this problem.
Okay, so here we've got,
first at the top here we've got
a definition of
the fold function,
so this is a left fold.
We've got flip which flips
the order of its arguments.
We've got reverse implemented
in terms of fold and flip.
Then finally we have
a function palindrome
that checks to see if a list is
a palindrome by
checking to see whether
the original list is equal
to the reverse of the list.
Does anybody see the bug
in this program?
Okay. So, the bug
in this program,
well let's see what GHC
has to say about it.
So, here's what GHC says.
So, GHC gives us
this sort of complicated,
but ultimately it gives us
a location for the error.
So, it says the problem is
in reverse xs equals equals xs.
Okay. That looks fine to me.
So, it turns out
that's not really
where the conceptual
source of the error.
So, the conceptual source
of the error is that
our base case of fold l is wrong.
So, the very first line
of fold l is incorrect.
That should just be,
we should just return
the base case there,
not a list containing
the base case.
So, there is an error in
the base case of fold.
But fold without
any type annotations
actually type checks.
The use of fold later
in the reverse function
also type checks.
We don't actually detect
the error until sort of this
two uses later in
the palindrome function when
GHC finally detects the error.
Okay, so this is the problem,
and we can see it
exhibited here in GHC.
Okay, so there's
been lots of work
on how to improve error location.
So, the solution, so
this has actually
work by Senchen and Martin Erwig,
so two of my collaborators,
but this is a really
cool application,
I think of variational
programming.
So, basically the
problem is that locating
the cause of a type
errors is hard.
The reason is that type
inference commits too early.
So, here when fold
type-checks correctly,
it commits to the type
that it infers for fold.
But the problem is that
a successfully inferred type
could still be wrong.
So, just because
type inference succeeded,
doesn't necessarily
mean that type
that was inferred
is the correct one.
So, the solution is that
when we infer correct type,
we still sort of keep open
the possibility that
that type could be wrong.
So, we assume that
the type either could be correct
or could still be wrong.
So, the way counterfactual
typing works
is that we basically perform
variational type inference.
So, error tolerant
here means that if
one particular branch of
type inference fails,
we don't fail the whole process.
This is important because
we're dealing with
a program of type errors in it?
But for every subexpression,
so every single subexpression in
our program when we
infer a type T for
the subexpression e,
we instead introduced
a choice type here.
So, we instead say e is
a choice and sum dimension
d that's either the type
that we inferred,
or it's a fresh
type variable here.
So, the dimension is fresh and
the type variable is fresh.
We do this everywhere.
When we're done, we get
this variational result
with lots of dimensions
in it and we're going to
search that variational
type that we get
back for a value that's
not an error type,
and that has as few
right selections as possible.
So, right selections
correspond to places
where the inferred
type was wrong.
So, we want a type
where we have to,
this basically is a measure
of how many changes we have
to make in order to
fix our program.
So, it's basically
saying what was
written here was wrong,
and so we're sort of using
this type variable to capture
that we might have put
anything else in there,
anything with a different type.
So, we search
our variational type
for something where we have
to make as few right
choices as possible.
It turns out that this
gives us the location
where we have
to make the smallest number
of changes to find the error,
or to fix the error as possible.
Then we apply
some other heuristics that
help us be better than
everybody else before us.
Okay, so that's one problem.
Oh shoot, I'm slightly over.
So, we also apply this
to gradual typing.
It's really cool, but I took way
too long explaining
the other thing.
So, let me just say real quick,
so gradual typing is all
about mixing static
and dynamic types,
but a big problem with them is
migrating between
graduate type programs,
so the problems
that can occur are
that when you're adding
type annotations,
you can get into a place
where you sort of can't add
anymore type annotations,
but you're not in the most
statically type program.
There's also potential for
huge performance degradation.
So, there's papers written
about how gradual typing
is broken fundamentally
because of
this performance
degradation problem.
So, basically the idea
is that we do
the same trick that we did
in counterfactual typing,
and we can basically
introduce choice types
for every parameter,
and explore the whole space of
potential gradual
type integrations,
and find ones that satisfy
different criteria that we want.
So, this paper was
at POPL this year.
I put little crossed fingers next
to ICFP. Our reviews were good.
So, hopefully in
a week we'll find
out if we have
an ICFP paper on it too.
Okay, so sorry I went over
variational programming
makes variation explicit,
and we can use this to explore
hypothetical scenarios. Thanks.
Okay. Are there any questions for
Eric, about variational
programming?
It's late in the
afternoon, don't be shy.
One thing I was curious about.
You mentioned like
simulations as a bad option,
but actually there's a lot of
simulation packages that have
a lot of variations for accuracy.
So, like Seagull, is the one
that sticks out in my mind,
where they had like
80 different flavors
depending on how
much are you willing
to spend on floating
point. I wonder-
>> So, I guess the reason I
assume numerical simulations
will be bad is because
we never have this situation
where alternatives converge
to the same value.
So, in typing, this happens a lot
because different
configurations have
the same type and so we can
forget about
the choices basically,
but yeah, I don't know, we
can talk about this more.
Maybe in this case where it's
different amounts of precision,
maybe this does occur.
>> Well actually the problem
is they don't converge back,
so you're totally right there.
That's why there's
BIF. All right.
Any other questions for Eric?
Okay. So, up next.
Oh, I'm so sorry, Doug.
>> I have no idea if this is
a good question, but, so,
you mentioned that you've
had trouble finding anything
general with variational
data structures?
Is there something
about derivatives
of types that would help here?
It seems like your variational
data structures are
like you're you're
modifying something in some way
you want to record
those modifications?
>> Yeah. So, I thought about
this like using zippers
or something like this.
Yeah. So, I still think there's
potential for this here,
but problem is just
that you can get
better performance than
introducing choices
in a derivative of a data type
by just doing something special.
So, I mean, this is hard
to say without examples,
but I'm here, we can talk
about this offline maybe.
>> Awesome. Okay. Let's
thank Eric again.
So up next, Brad is going to
tell us about what's been
going on with the Chapel
Language at Cray.
>> Great. Thanks. So,
I'm Brad Chamberlain,
I'm a Principal Engineer at Cray,
here in Seattle, and I'm
the technical lead for
the Chapel Project which I'll be
talking a bit about today.
This is the official
title for my talk,
but I have this bad
habit of making up
dumb titles the night
before I give talks,
so this'll make more sense
as we go along.
If you're not
familiar with Chapel,
it's a productive parallel
programming language that
we're developing at Cray.
It's portable and scalable,
which means it can run on
your laptop, your cluster,
the cloud on a Cray,
and it's open source
and collaborative,
which means we're
developing it in GitHub,
under the Apache license.
The two main goals of Chapel are
to support general
parallel programming,
which you can think of as,
if you've got a parallel
algorithm in your mind and
some parallel hardware
you'd like to run it on,
Chapel should be able to do that.
The second goal is to
make parallel programming
at scale far more productive
than it is today.
Now, that term productive
means different things
to different people.
One way that I'll explain it
is to compare to other languages.
So, one language that's easy
to read and write code in,
let's say a Python,
but yet is as fast as a Fortran,
as scalable as MPI,
which is how most people do
large-scale HPC programming
today, as portable as C,
as flexible as C++
and as fun as your favorite
programming language,
so that you get excited
about using Chapel.
So, one way that we'll
visualize how we're
doing here is by looking at
the Computer Language
Benchmarks Game,
and here I've taken the
languages that are involved
in the game and I've plotted
two points for each one,
which are the geometric means
of their fastest programs
and their smallest programs
in terms of code size.
So, the closer they are to
the bottom of the slide,
the faster the languages.
The closer they are to the left,
the smaller the codes
are in the language.
So as you'd expect,
the scripting languages are
further off to the left
here but much slower,
and if we zoom in on who's down
there at the right, we see C,
C++, Fortran and rest,
but of course their codes
are also much bigger.
Now, I've left Chapel off here,
but if we add the Chapel
entries to this,
then were off here
down to the left,
which you can think of as
being productive because
you're fast and small,
and if I zoom back
out, we're again,
uniquely down to
the left compared to
where most other
languages fit nowadays.
Now of course, we all know
that language succinctness
isn't necessarily
the best metric of productivity.
So, the website also lets you
go in and look at the programs,
and for the Chapel,
you can see things like
these high-level cobegin
again and coforall constructs,
which create tasks,
whereas in the C entry, you can
see things like sched_getaffinity
and things that hopefully most of
you have never had to
deal with in your life.
So, that's a little bit
about Chapel.
When I was approaching
this talk, I said, well,
I could talk about
a number of things and
my reviewers each wanted me to
talk about something different,
which I should have anticipated.
But one of the quotes
that stuck out
for me was this one which said,
"Chapel has been around
for quite awhile,
and it still seems like
a niche language."
Which is one of the things
that hurts your heart here,
but is arguably true
and I think a lot of people
share this perspective.
So, I wanted to dive into
this a little bit and say,
first of all, are we
a niche language?
One way in which you
could view us as being
niche is that Chapel
was originally
designed for HPC and HPC
is arguably a niche field
within computer science.
But that said, if we step
back and look at Chapel,
Chapel cares about performance
and I think a lot of
people who even outside of
HPC care about performance,
we've heard a lot
about that today.
Chapel cares about
programmability and I think
the rise of things like Python
show that people care about that.
Chapel cares about
parallelism and
multicore means that
we're all arguably
able to be parallel
programmers nowadays and it
also cares about scalability
or distributed memory,
and with the rise
of cloud computing,
you can see that that has
become bigger and
bigger over time.
So, I would argue that Chapel,
while developed
originally for HPC,
actually has a lot
of applicability
outside of HPC as well,
and as the language matures
we're hearing that from a lot
of non HPC programmers as well.
Another way you could consider
us niche is that we really
have a very modest sized
user community,
like it's not a Python,
we'd love to be as
large and successful
community as Python is.
But something you have to
know is that historically,
if you came to me and said,
"Should I program my next
production app in Chapel?"
Historically, my answer has been,
no probably not yet,
and that gets me to
the quiche part of the talk.
So, I think a lot of people
in the community who
maybe heard about Chapel
over its lifetime say like,
"Why aren't more people using
this delectable language?"
In their mind they've
got this picture
of this lovely quiche
that we've been making.
But the reality is that over
the large fraction of
the program's history,
we've been putting
this quiche together
and you probably don't
want to eat it just yet,
but read the recipe,
sample the ingredients,
see if you think we're
on a path that's going
to be attractive to you.
I say where we are today is here
where it's perhaps
almost fully baked,
and maybe it's time to
take a look at it again,
if it's something that's
of interest to you.
So, going to the other part
of that reviewer comment
that has been around
for quite a while,
so that's accurate as well.
Chapel came out of
the DARPA HPCS program
that ran from 2003 to 2012.
At that time, we were
very much research focus,
a small team of 6-7 people,
and I think we accomplished
some great research objectives
in the parallel language area,
but at the end of the day we
had a research prototype,
we didn't have something
that people can really use.
So, what we've been
doing since then is
what we call the five-year push.
This has been
a five-year effort to
basically move Chapel from
research more to product,
and we doubled the size of
the team as part of that,
and we focused on
these three main areas:
performance and scalability,
building up the ecosystem around
Chapel and fixing things in
the base language
that weren't directly
related to parallelism
or scalability.
This third one is probably of
most interest to this crowd,
but doesn't fit at all
in a 10 minute talk.
So, I'm going to touch
slightly on the first two,
and I'm going to compare then,
where were we at the end of HPCS
and the start of this push,
versus now, where are we today?
I'll start with an ecosystem
then versus now.
So, when we came out of HPCS,
in terms of documentation,
we had a PDF language
specification,
we had a Quick Reference sheet,
we had a number of text-based
README files and we had
some primer examples
that taught you
the language through
comments and code.
Now, we're at a point
where we have over
200 modern hyperlinked web
based documentation pages,
and when you surf to
Chapel, it feels more like
a real language and less
like somebody's experiment.
In terms of libraries
at the end of HPCS,
we had about 25 library modules,
some of them were
documented in source code,
some of them were not
really documented at all.
We're now at a point
where we have
about 60 library modules,
all of them are
document on the web
and many of these have
been user contributed.
Then in terms of tools,
at the end of HPCS,
we had highlighting
modes for emacs and vim,
we had chpldoc or
at least a rough draft,
which was a documentation
tool and now we
have those as well as
mason package manager,
c2chapel aid for
interoperability,
chpltags which allows you
to search your source code,
bash tab completion and then this
performance visualizer over
on the side here chplvis,
so a lot of great improvements
to the ecosystem.
Performance is
another thing which has
traditionally been a
problem for Chapel.
If you ask most people in
HPC about Chapel they say,
"Oh, it's that really
pretty language
that performs really terribly."
In HPC, of course,
that's a killer.
So, over the last five years
we've done a lot
with performance,
this is a bit of
a laundry list, but in short,
we've done a lot of
locality oriented things,
particularly within
multi-socket nodes
and a lot of communication
reduction across nodes.
So, if I went back
to where we then,
this is a stream performance
benchmark and higher is better,
and I'm adding nodes across
the axis of the bottom here.
So, you could see that
as we added nodes,
the performance got
better as you'd expect,
but if you compare that
to where we are today,
we've already have a third
of the performance
we're getting today,
and of course now you should
be suspicious and say,
well, how do we know
that you're good today?
Well, if we compare to
the reference version
in green here,
you can see that we're
tracking it pretty closely,
we're just a little bit of
hit due to our elegance.
Looking in second example,
this is a Stencil computation at
that end of HPCS time period.
Again, it's getting
faster as we add nodes,
but if we add today's onto their,
basically the red line goes
all the way down to the axis,
we just were terrible in terms
of raw performance then,
and again if I had been
the reference you can
see that we're tracking
it very closely today.
So, you can look at this across
a number of HPC computations.
These handle things like
just Local loops,
Embarrassing Parallelism,
Bucket-Exchange, Stencils,
Global Random Updates,
and in all these cases were doing
quite well compared to
the reference version.
I'll go into one more,
in a bit more detail,
the Global Random Updates here.
This is the code for the MPI
version of this benchmark,
as you can see, it's almost
as elegant as Chapel.
At the top, there is a comment
and this comment tells
you what this code does.
Basically, it's just doing
random updates to globally
distributed table.
This is the chapel loop for
that same kernel
and as you can see
the actual computation is about
the size of the of
the MPI computation.
This is another case
where we're not only
scaling competitively with
the reference version,
but in fact outperforming it.
Okay, so what's next for us?
Next week, we've got
our annual workshop.
It'll be up in Vancouver.
So it's localish this year.
If you've got friends or
colleagues or students who are
interested in parallel
computing and
languages, send them up.
It's generally considered
a high-energy workshop,
and as we look forward,
we're kicking off
a new three-year effort
where we're going
to continue to work
on performance and scalability.
I'm targeting Libfabric,
targeting GPUs,
targeting the cloud
and working on AI.
This is our team at Cray.
Again, they're about 13 of us
working on it full-time
at any given time.
We also have
an intern program and
we'd love to have
your students apply to that.
It's an open source efforts.
We have community
partners as well.
You notice there's a sort
of disturbing lack
of civic Northwest education and
industry on here and we'd
love to correct that if
anyone would like to
collaborate in this area.
I think just to leave you here,
I will just skip ahead
to my summary slide.
So we've made huge progress
over the past five years.
We think chapels
ready for production,
but I put an asterisk
there because
different people have
different ideas what
production means and again
we're open to collaborations.
Last thing I'll mention
is that we have
some chapel swag in
the form of screen or
glasses wipes up here on
the chair if you need
one and I've got
five minutes for questions.
>> I can start off.
I have a question.
>> All right.
>> So you showed how
versus at the end
of the Darpa Program, HPCS.
>> HPCS.
>> Yeah, the end of HPCS,
compared to that, your
performance is way, way better.
>> Right.
>> Is the code the same?
Are you running the same program
and getting that much
better performance
or are the implementations
updated as well?
>> Yeah. No, so in this case,
what we did was we
took today's code
and we actually took
that old release
in random space hardware.
So it's as apples to
apples as possible.
In some cases, we have
to take the code and
maybe sometimes we relied
on a newer feature.
We had to rewrite that using
a slightly older feature
in order to get it to
run on the old version,
but by and large, it's the
more or less the same user code
that you would write.
So, yeah. So it's meant to be
as fair like comparison
as possible,
and it just speaks to how
poor we were in that time frame
in terms of performance.
>> Another thing
I'm curious about.
So in this distributed setting,
I mean if you have some kind
of work stealing or something,
depending on how the schedule
ends up you might
do floating point operations
in a different order.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you ever worry about that
like even just reproducibility?
>> So, right. So, certainly,
reproducibility is a concern
among some of Cray's customers
and they sort of
want things just so.
We don't actually do
much in the way of
work stealing at
least across nodes,
but still it's a parallel
language you tend to
have operations happening in
different orders and
things like that.
So we have ways of kind
of locking down order,
but, of course,
at the expense of parallelism and
therefore maybe performance
for people who
do need that reproducibility.
But in general, you can render
the sorts of errors like
we saw in the floating
point talk earlier.
If you do things in
the wrong order,
like you may get
wildly different results
and that sort of goes along with
parallel computing
and unfortunately as
the world we're used to
living in for the most part.
>> Do you guys have sort of like
regression tests to ensure that,
I guess you have
some flag that's like
make this reproducible.
>> Right.
>> It seems they get
the whole way down, right?
There's both on the network,
there's across cores and
then even within the core.
If you want to exploit
70 a lot of times,
you'll do some enrolling
in reassociation.
So I mean there's
so many levels for
reproducibility for
these kinds of large jobs.
How do you make sure that you've
actually found all of them?
That seems really tough.
>> Yeah, I don't think we
have a really good solution
there to be perfectly honest.
>> It's interesting,
research challenge.
If somebody in the region is
looking to collaborate,
maybe you could think about.
>> We would love
collaborations around,
and I think you guys have
the chops for it as well.
I see two hands here, Charlie.
>> So, you said
you're cloud-ready.
How easy is a pre-startup say
100 chapel nodes on
someone's cloud?
>> So, today,
the main cloud that we've had
the most experience with is
AWS and there's sort of
a Read Me that tells you how
to grab the thing and set up
your machine image
just so and build it.
We've talked about
building a sort of
pre-deployed machine
image so you can
just grab it without
having to do the build
and everything,
but we've never quite
cross that path.
We're interesting in
doing the same for
the other major cloud providers.
So if any of you
happen to work for
them and would be
influencing that,
we'd love to work
with you on that.
Yeah. But our implementation
is very portable.
So, generally speaking,
most of the cloud providers
have some sort of Linux kind of
option and that tends
to work fine for us.
Okay. Question at
the back there maybe.
>> Yeah. So if
you want to run
these algorithms on the cloud,
then it's probably longer
running algorithms.
Some machines don't
work as intended.
What do you do about [inaudible]?
>> Yes, so I would
say that we share,
the HPCS has traditionally have
this theme of like just
run fast, and if it fails,
run again or checkpoint restart,
and we haven't done anything
in chapel so far any
better than that.
So if the machine fails,
we don't sort of do anything
magical or automatic there,
and that's another area
where we'd like to do
additional research potentially
in a collaborative manner.
So, again, if that's
a topic of interest on
people in the room,
I would be very interested
on talking me about that.
>> Cool.
>> Okay.
>> Let's thank Brad again.
>> Okay. So, up next,
we have John Leo.
He's going to tell us about
type theory and music.
That's something you
hear combined every day.
It's ornaments in music.
If I know John, there's going
to be types in there. Okay.
>> For sure.
>> All right, so I would
like to start out with
some a little bit of
background and motivation
and then I'll talk
a little bit about kind
of a fun project I've
been working on.
This is available online,
but it's still very preliminary.
So it will probably
change quite drastically.
So I'd like to start out
with my favorite quote by
Bob Harper which is worth
savoring for a moment.
"Eventually all the arbitrary
programming languages
are going to just be swept
away with the oceans,
and we will have the permanence
of constructive,
intuitionistic type theory as
the master theory of computation,
without doubt in
my mind, no question.
So, from my point of view,
this is a personal statement,
working in anything else
is a waste of time."
So I love this quote.
I agree with that.
I'm really into both math and
computer science and I love
to see this convergence.
So the second question asks,
what will programming
look like in 50 years?
I kind of agree with
Bob's vision about this.
We already have kind of
things pointing the way.
There's functional programming.
There's a lot of
work been done in
algebra programming
mostly based at Oxford,
actually, using math
in your programming.
Then, now, that
was mostly done in
the context of
pure functional programming,
but now we have dependent types
where you can do
even more math and
then there's even newer
things coming out.
Now, there's cubicle type
theory and so forth.
But there's also a question, who
does the programming because,
I mean, certainly,
from my experiences,
most programmers hate math.
So they're really willing
to learn all this.
But I don't know, maybe
50 years from now.
The computers will be
programming themselves.
But I think they'll be doing it,
written there and
programming and type theory.
All right, so given,
this is the goal, how do
we actually get there?
So we have some finally some kind
of industrial strength of
functional programming languages
Haskell and OCaml.
So we can try adding
independent types to
them and certainly that's
being done for Haskell,
and even now in Haskell
you can kind of fake
dependent types using a ton of
extensions, but it's very ugly.
Another way to do
it is just takes
some language that was designed
from the start for dependent
type something like add
their interests and try to
make it practical to use.
I think it'll be
interesting to see
which one of those two wins out.
Meanwhile, how do we even
program using dependent types?
This is really something
that no one's done yet.
I mean, no one's trying to write
dependently type programming
for industry or whatever.
I've done functional programming
in industry and even then it's
not exactly clear what's
the right way to write
functional programming stuff.
It's still kind of
even in infancy,
independent types is even
not even up to that level.
It's clear there's still
going to be a lot of
both theoretical and
practical advances
needed to get to this point.
Say with these are all
interesting things to look at,
what I want to
concentrate here on
is let's actually start
trying to program
using dependent types.
So going back a little bit.
When I was first learning
Haskell in 2014,
I came across
this wonderful book by
Paul Hudak and a system
that he had written
called Euterpea,
which was a system to do music,
and I'm very interested
in music and I've done
a little composition
and stuff like that.
But I'm very lazy because
I don't want to have to
spend a lot of time on it.
I actually have
some music software,
but none of it's been quite
what I wanted to use.
But the Euterpea was
actually close to what
I don't want to do.
Here is something where
we could represent music.
Using a programming language,
you could kind of do
mathy types of things with it.
So it seemed very cool to use.
So, but the utopia
was kind of based on old Haskell
and stuff like that.
I thought well maybe I can make
a better more modern version.
So, I started working on
something called music tools.
It's just basically,
the idea is as
small toolkit of
very small programs
that have a very
specific purpose and you can
combine them together using
functional programming
techniques or whatever,
and with the idea
to help you synthesize and
analyze music and so forth.
So, I originally
wrote it in Haskell,
but then I thought going
back to this thing
of dependent types are
the greatest thing,
why am I not using them.
So, I tried converting it to
AGDA and actually
it's interesting
because actually even
found some bugs in
the Haskell version when I
made the types more specific.
So, it actually already was
paying off a little bit.
I saw these Haskell
would actually
get anything to have
IO and so forth.
But it actually worked
out pretty well
and I think it's a good domain
to actually start with because
dependent type languages are
not exactly performing yet,
but here's something
where we don't
need incredible performance.
We can kind of do
stuff in batch mode
and it's still reasonably fast.
And it's a nice domain, right?
Music is fairly
well-described and so forth,
but it's still fairly rich.
And then the exciting
thing too is,
I've been doing some research
with Talia and Nate and Dan,
and some of the stuff that we're
doing look like it would
apply to this as well.
So, I thought well, here's
a chance I can play with this.
So, I wasn't sure if I'd
have time to play any music,
but I have some requests,
so maybe I'll see if this works.
So, here's a little piece
that I wrote,
a very simple song
I wrote back in
the day and this is
actually I kind of
re-implemented it in.
We'll see if this
works, well, maybe not.
All right. Well,
sorry about that.
>> You might just
try to play it on
your speakers on the laptop.
>> Yeah, but then I
have to figure out how
to change the audio output,
so anyway, don't worry about it.
But, I show it to you
a little bit what it looks like.
So basically,
there's kind of four lines
here a melody, accompaniment,
bass and drums and
the melody I essentially
just wrote out for now,
but there's actually
some structure to it
and I could take
advantage of that or
maybe everyone what's
maybe interested in is how
the program can figure out
the structure and recreate it.
But as you can see for
the accompaniment has
a little more structure,
so we're actually able to use
some functional
programming things,
you see maps and zips and
stuff like that in there.
And the bass and the drums
even more structures,
you can make them
even more minimal.
In fact, the very first thing I
did with utopia was tried to
write minimum version
of the hands on
exercises with them if you
know those piano exercises.
All right. So anyway, to
get this to work and
have a nice tool,
we need a good
representation of music,
how do you represent music?
And I've thought
about it for a while,
and I don't think is
a perfect representation.
There's a lot of good ways
to do it and they all
have pluses and minuses.
So, right now I'm using something
that's pretty close
to utopia where
pitches and durations
they kind of
make notes out of them
and then music out of
that and you can compose things
sequentially or in parallel.
But, you may notice there's
some ambiguity here,
you can kind of represent music
and in multiple ways
that sound equivalent.
There's equivalence
kind of structurally,
there's equivalent
musical equivalence
and this is something utopia
has to deal with as well.
For example, you can have
zero length rests in there,
which actually is
a common thing you'll do if
you're folding and near
zero length is your base case.
So, here's just
even a more concrete example
for pitch itself,
we can represent as a sort of
absolute pitch which
I have at the top,
but then we could
also represent it
as a relative pitch within
an octave and then
paired with the octave.
So now, if we wrote all these
functions using one,
we want to actually
use them using
the other one, what do you do?
You can convert back
and forth and so forth.
But, the nice thing is there's
some nice research being
done on this that we can
actually apply here.
So, the homotopy type theory
gives you a way
to first define equivalence
and then lift it up to functions
based on that equivalence.
And now, since we're
using independent types,
we can take advantage of
this research and actually do it.
So, there's been
some work on this,
there's a paper equivalences
for free which might
also appear on ICFP we'll see,
done by some people
in Inria, in Caulk,
and I've been moving this
over to the AGDA world
and using it for that.
But there's still some problems
here even though you do get
a lot of equivalences for free,
just the base equivalences
themselves can be rather
painful to define,
and it seems like this
could be automated
in some way and I
think the work actually
Talia is doing
now should be very
very helpful for this.
So, even beyond equivalences,
so my definition of
music I left out something
that was in who'd axe,
you had an extra little thing,
this modify control.
And so,
this actually has some extra
information and in fact,
you can even put
ornaments in your music.
But I'm not sure I want
to do it this way,
I'm still thinking about it,
but this is the way I think just
in Stewart's talk today
is talking about you know
adding this native thing to
the other things and then it's
going to pervade
everything, right?
So, here too, we
have this kind of
core musical thing
but then we have
this extra information we want to
add and how can we
deal with that.
And so here there's
another ornaments
which Talia nicely had already
talked about in her talk,
which is kind of
you can think of as
a generalization of
equivalences where now
you have more information
on one side than the other.
And again, you can kind of do
this automatic lifting
and so forth with that.
So, this is also something
I'm adding to this.
Here the main challenge has
been that all this work
although it's actually done
in AGDA which is nice for me,
they did all with deep
embeddings which made it very
nice for them to do
theoretical things with it,
but we need a shallow
embedding in AGDA.
So, I'm using
reflection mechanism in
AGDA to try to convert between
the deep and
the shallow embeddings.
So, to conclude I
think this has been
a great application area
and I'm looking forward
to playing with it more.
Just like types,
people don't want
to put in the effort
to do math at first,
it's a lot of work, but I
think it pays off in the end.
And then part of
the goal of this project
is to figure out how to
minimize that work and
still get the rewards
of using the math.
>> Any questions for John?
So, starting, Earl.
Oh go head. Yes.
>> [inaudible] just
too early to sing.
>> It's too early in a way,
but I think already
the equivalences stuff
has been really nice.
So, it's very promising. Yeah.
>> So, this is for on
the AI side on styled transfers,
people do it are also presumably
music you like and to
make a box style so,
does that relate to this?
>> Yeah, this is intended to be
a foundation to do that stuff.
There's actually
even a lot of other work,
there's a lot of stuff
in Haskell going on now,
there's something called
the harm trace to things to do
harmonic analyses and they use
the type system to enforce
harmonic rules and
stuff like that.
And this is, again,
this is intended to
be a base system that
all that can be built
out of and I think I can
redo for example
the harm trace stuff using
the peno types will
be a lot more elegant
than what they're doing now with
a lot of Haskell
extensions again.
>> So, you mentioned
that you need
a shallow embedding is that for
the media interface
through Haskell?
>> No. That's just to
get the ornaments stuff
to work on real AGDA code.
So right now you'd need
to, in the deep embedding,
you need to define
all your types and as this
embedded thing
instead of using like
real natural numbers
or whatever even.
So, they define these
things as fixed points of
functors in their deep embedding
and things like that.
So, it's a matter of translating
between these two worlds.
>> Okay, any more
questions for John?
All right. So, let's
thank John again.